should we you know have families with
one name should women take their
husband's name should the kid have the
father's name there's three reasons why
they should the husband is the head of
the household as such everyone should
have his name it's a family unit okay
maybe you think that's a little too old
timing and traditional For You Second
reason women carry the baby women have a
very close connection to the baby the
man's relationship to the baby you know
it's a relatively quick contribution
with the baby taking the man's name it
joins these two things together the man
will never have the physical bond with
the baby that a mother has but they will
be a family unit they will have his name
but the third reason is that that baby
will inevitably have a man's surname the
baby will either have his father's last
name or his maternal grandfather's last
name